bon alors on va alors quand yann le
jingle parce qu'on met le titre et tout
ça il faut pas bouger parce que sinon ça
oblige à figer l'image donc lumière
et voilà c'est pas beau ça cela m'amuse
six jours après sa très courte mais moi
j'ai pas compris comment on écrit par le
jeu en bouche mais ça évite de le figer
l'image à réagir c'est bon vous êtes
prête
oui bon aure dernier coup un votre
dernier coup dur
dernier coup dur des histoires de
personnel de par rapport à mes enfants
auxquels je tiens enfin qui sont mes
compagnons de vie quoi aux gens je les
ai donc voilà des choses de ma vie
j'étais malade
nous dénonçons gérer les cas légers pas
en parler par rapport à un jour est
celle des piscines on me dit que ce
bagage non bien le dernier coup de tête
téléphoner à un copain j'ai pas nominé
supra 3 à 3 heures du mat non mais oui
non mais je devrai dormi en lui disant
bienvenue
non non non non à bord notre nom se
mêlent pas un coup de tête
maintenant j'ai l'esprit mal tourné
dernier coup de foudre d'un rapport à un
homme amoureusement voyons alors là
cette façon tu n'es pas bon non ben on
m'a lancé un appel non merci je vois
comme un lâche d'emblée pas qu'on joue
avec un numéro vert non on comme votre
père vous engueuler si vous notez que
failli me regarde le désir la télé en
plus c'est très bien que nous sommes
bien avec maman aussi voyager disney
tout ça mais mais mais il est ici oui tu
comprends ça il n'est pas juste un
trophée maintenant il sait que je pense
que oui mais pas que c'est le gros mot
des trucs plutôt jusque là où jusque là
elle s'est bien comportée
alors là j'ai michèle cotta michèle
cotta l'ami d'un ami jay benêt syrie
franchement on t'aime bien mais là tu
exagères voilà la wii dans votre père
qui était un journaliste sur leurs
terres pour bien le dire absolument être
toilettée roc est en un an plus tard
dakar votre père si si je suis ni da kg
meryem je connais tous deux nous n'avons
pas me raconter d'histoires moi non
dernier coup de rein de rein devra donc
l'amour hier a alors assuré que j'espère
que monsieur célarié rassurer donc là
bas oui papa si on va pas parce que sa
fille donc c'était pas avec le dernier
coup de foudre s'était ses dessins via
le coach oui mais c'est pas un coup de
chaud excusez moi je comprends la non
mais je les aime beaucoup mais je sais
coup de foudre
ah oui d'accord sur le coup de grâce
avec un copain non moi j'ai les coûts de
foot je sais pas trop parce que moi je
tombe souvent mais amoureuse forcément
dob je dirai ce que je dis [ __ ] vous
êtes mieux quand vous faites pas
attention je parle des hommes ça se
retourne contre moi à mort n'est pas une
vie c'est vrai classique et que les gens
vous l'aurez vous et 42 ans je ne suis
pas mariée je ne suis pas installé dans
une vie c'est comme ça j'y peux rien et
puis ya plein d'autres femmes comme ça
et puis et puis crottes
mais bon voilà non mais c'est non mais
oui normal et les très jeunes à 40,2 au
départ
et plusieurs fois sur l'historique donc
après en vous et qui vous avez des
articles dit n'importe quoi cherchons
pas des trucs c'est pour ça c'est rien
n'y a pas assez de temps pour en parler
pour que ce soit bien mes coups droits
on va en rester là c'était hier soir oui
mais un coup de rein pour moi c'était de
l'amour
ces deux là c'est pas du sexe à best non
oui c'est de l'amour mais l'amour qu'on
va laisser le sexe et la vie d'amour
dedans non franchement ça ne m'intéresse
pas du tout d'accord ben avis aux
amateurs n'ont été allumé la lumière de
vue entre le show